um I feel like strange might have tried
anything for trying to sign you your
technology Travis we spoke I did a they
push a hard line super hard I mean
they're strict it's like it's kind of
like it's because it's a boot camp
boot camp for sure like you go on tour
and get fined and [__] me and Tech are
like this like that's that's my brother
man and take a show me so much love and
game I remember my first time going to
Kansas City doing the show shortly after
uh Max Ray was assassinated
um
Tech came to the show and was like I'm
not letting nothing happen
it was there security guards they
probably talking about from me entering
Kansas City to me leaving he was with me
right and I was just like
how did you get my number like this is
like he just called me like what's up
it's Tech Nine I'm like Tech what's up
where you at
like man you got candy tonight right
pulling up
and he just stayed with me it was like
nothing's gonna happen to you for people
who don't know Mac Dre was murdered in
Kansas City man and and
um Tech
uh
and Joe and like the whole Squad Travis
made sure that he was cool man and like
man like yeah but the Strange Music like
bro
they so militant like
when Tech goes on tour Tech does like 98
days 98 dates in like 100 and 100 days
right it's kind of wild it's no rooms
you're showering at and he's expecting a
baby right now so I I don't know how
that's gonna happen like bro you
showering that truck stops for sure you
got to get up at six in the morning you
got to deal with those those strange
music fans who are special kind of fan
at the end of the show you gotta wait
till all the meet and greet and the
sign-ins and all that's done so you
might have performed at nine o'clock
you're not leaving that City till two
o'clock right
you got to be at the next city at a
certain time you got a shower I said I
went out I say
it's a bougie for this that's so funny I
don't know I don't want to be this type
of successful this is a different level
of success I love my freedom brother I
want to shower in a nice place I am the
room type I am the the I got to go go to
the hotel I got to catch an airplane man
I can't do it like I'm I don't know say
it wasn't meant for me to get to get on
that way sometimes you got to realize
man you gotta really applaud those
people that put in that extra effort and
Tech N9 is the reason why he is and the
reason why they're successful as they
are because the behind the scenes work
that they put in oh my God the average
artist wouldn't last that's a real rap
boot camp like that's like do you come
in here it's there you got to be ready
for sure so I love them and I salute
them like for what they do man them
dudes are definitely deserving of
everything that they get